of all the demos we've had here on the
GameSpot stage at San Diego comic-con
this one is by far the most populated as
you can see joining me on the couch I
have Robert kaki from Activision and
Caracas on and Sheeta hama-san from
Platinum Games here to talk about the
Legend of Korra gentlemen welcome to the
stage thank you very excited to have you
here especially you guys from platinum
who have flown across the sea to talk
about legend of korra thank you for
coming yeah Oh chuckles OH all right so
legend of korra let's let's talk about
it a little bit give a quick overview
because i think a lot of you folks have
probably heard of Avatar The Last
Airbender and if you haven't come on
guys
but The Legend of Korra you know very
connected to that franchise it's all
sort of part of the same franchise but
where does it distinguish itself sort of
give us the baseline right so um you
know Avatar The Last Airbender obviously
highly acclaimed really cool show it's
not that whole thing where if the
different nations and each of them have
like a type of vendor which is like a
person who controls elements so you have
fire earth air and water and the avatar
is kind of the guy that or the person
that kind of keeps the peace and also
it's like the bridge between the spirit
world and the real world and so legend
of korra is basically the sequel of that
takes place over 50 years later and
basically the the avatars been reborn as
a headstrong teenage girl named Korra
mm-hmm and you can kind of follow her
adventures in the show and it's been
it's gotten really good I mean
incredible acclaim it's really well
known it's got a very avid fan base and
so we're super excited to be working on
it and the whole Airbender universe kind
of lends itself to video games
especially action video games the kind
that Platinum excels at you know because
you have all the elemental powers so
let's jump in right now and just see
some of the game in action sure and sort
of give us a setup for where we're gonna
be starting here in the demo yeah so
okay well before we before you do that I
will note note that this game is not yet
done okay so everything's not completely
final yet but it's in a pretty good
place already so we're definitely
excited to show it but yeah in the
actual game so I won't give away too
much but the so just a few things to
note the story was written by
one of the head writers on the actual
show nighttime Hedrick it was you know
the concept was developed in tandem with
the actual creators of the show Mike and
Brian so and it actually takes place
within the core universe officially so
it's between actually the vents of book
2 and book 3 okay so this is like if you
were following the show I don't I'll try
not to give away too much of what
happens in book 2 but the crazy stuff
goes down around Republic City sure
we're gonna see a little bit of that so
I'm just let me know and so we're kind
of in that setting but basically in the
story what happened was there's the
strange old guy and she has no idea who
he is but he's basically uh knocked her
out and she wakes up and she has none of
her powers what god I know shocking
right and so what kind of videogame is
that gonna be van air yeah but uh so
basically she is she doesn't know what's
going on she she goes to her mentor
Tenzin who it's actually Aang's avatar
hang some infomercials series and she is
trying to figure what's going on so he
lives it air temple island and so she
goes there to try and find him he's not
there and in fact it's been invaded by
chi-blockers which were originally shown
in the first book in the season and
mysteriously have reappeared so that's
kind of where she's at she's trying to
simultaneously get her bending back as
well as figure out what's going on beat
up some chi-blockers
probably so alright let's go yep so
we're gonna start in the middle of stage
this is a demo build so it's not 100% in
context with the story sure it's a
little bit more focused on gameplay but
I guess my normal three difficulty modes
no extreme yeah yeah alright so I you
know this as a score right so you is
this sort of that that video game trope
of she's lost all her powers you're
gonna get get them back one by one learn
how to use them and then bring them all
together and glorious it's bending in
his nominee it's more it's not this less
that she is relearning how to use them
it's more like she's gradually gaining
her power back oh come and actually for
the purposes of this demo we've actually
want everything so she doesn't actually
have anything back at this
well she is it full powered and actually
we want to just run through some stuff
you can do but in the actual game yeah
you'll start out with not much and then
you'll start
we get back up and it's it's a it's a
great way to get reintroduced to how all
the different fighting styles work so
well it looks lovely I mean it's got
that it's got a very crisp style that
sort of I you know sort of that kind of
immediate feel to it but then of course
the fluid animation of of the show and
right yeah I feel like when you make a
translation from a show of animated show
to a game some things are maybe a little
easier the color palettes out like that
but the animations you have to come up
with are so much more detailed than what
you have to show what you have to go out
in the show right
well they need to multiply you more
angles and all that stuff yeah these
guys can really talk to that well will
actually show up artwork they'll they'll
do a little spiel on it but so the first
thing I wanted was actually to introduce
the various bedding styles so one thing
we're really excited about for the
combat is um that you can switch styles
of any cells at any time like literally
mid combo you can switch bedding styles
and that leads to an incredible amount
of depth when you have all them together
mom so here right now is showing
waterbending and the idea is it's it's
open it's primarily long range and it
also is really good at juggling enemies
whether they're in the air it has a lot
of cool things like a grabber you can
grab enemies and pull them towards you
you can actually turn things into ice
thank you ice Decker's it's just really
effective in actually from inside of a
water dome yeah really
exactly and then next is a earthbending
which is much slower but incredibly
powerful and very disruptive your
breaking stuff yeah and it's got a lot
of barium affect stuff going on with it
it's also really good to knock up so
it's synergizes really well with
waterbending because you can knock them
up and then cut lumineer those an
earthquake move it actually staggers
enemies and then firebending
so firebending is incredibly fast it's
really focused on long combos and speed
it's also got a lot of mobility like you
can just see I'm just kind of jetting
around like that so and then I don't
have any any
and then airbending is the most
versatile of all of them it's got a
little bit everything and we'll we'll
see you in action but uh so one of the
fun things really really it's got a
little bit of everything by which you
mean also breakdancing exactly so yeah
it's got a lot of very effect it's got a
lot of - throughs which are a bit
advanced but even desperate guys like in
midair on the ground and consider the
combo on the other side kind of thing as
synergizes really well with other styles
so we're just a lot of stuff going on in
terms of you know the different styles
each have combos and Texas within
themselves but then because you can play
them all interchangeably that seems like
really a lot of different sort of combat
philosophies to fill combat niches to
fill in terms those your what range what
kind of what kind of damage you're doing
was that a little tough to all pull
together I mean that seems like
challenging to build that kind of combat
system sure I think that's a question
for sure awesome let's talk about you
said about hey sorry oh wow oh no matter
I don't know fighting quite actually
yeah hey you know company much - ok so
this name the only beginning oh no yo -
no bending good feet oh oh no sorry that
took choke at sea out there so you're
talking about maritime in what hip 100
but I'm not tuning Google tonight I'm
interested or also nope I'm not taking
you so now they
mm-hmm it's not gonna so he said yeah
because each of the different bidding
sales had like coming completely
different properties um it was
incredibly difficult to figure out a way
to make that work but through massive
amounts of tuning they were able to
really get come to a point where they
were able to make them combine really
smoothly together I'm pretty excited
about very cool and of course when
you're making the decisions about how
these combat styles fit together you
also have to design in tandem the type
of enemies you face because that you
know that's who you're using them on
it's so important to have them demand
things of you and be challenging and and
make you mix things up so what kind of
what kind of how did that influence your
approach to designing all the enemies
you face I don't know come on okay you
don't take you much thinner Jessica so
let's go anyone can you got hit so
Jeanette Scott muscle bending or the
state of all come like this and they
take your way to take out two more this
kid or my son or ma so there's our no
bending stereo no my talk show on your
dick string out taking off his angled
away you're so much nicer so it's not at
all starting a being a girl Co do not
dishonor you will need new O'Connor
others are no copper bending jock Tim
Morrison
means the world oh cool you know because
all my kid your buddy woke up that's
what I'm going on oh so it's a quiche
they're gonna take you let's go to it
stop doing that get all conquered also
yeah nice Walker so basically take your
big dick what's geo submission
it's the best way okay
aha user level not report we ending war
taking the hostage Kitty cut it did I
put it Thomasina give it time sorry - so
he's saying yeah for example so they're
basically all the different pinning
cells have their own specialties but
they also have their own weaknesses and
so a lot of the enemies are designed to
kind of take advantage of those so for
example water bending is great for long
range but doesn't do that much damage so
there are enemies that attempt to get
too close distance with you really
quickly and then the earth bending the
same way there are a lot of enemies that
move so it's a slower attacking type
some name they've got enemies that move
very quickly in order to be able to
avoid it so kind of keep the player on
their toes and kind of make it so that
you don't kick it through the whole game
just using one type of ending style sure
they definitely put a lot of thought
into that
well shooter Hamas on maybe you can go
oh you found an enemy to fight here as
it was that indicative of the enemy
being an earthbender it was early aim
down in the earth smashed out yep these
are the so the Triads also make an
appearance in this game it's kind of
like a mafia looking for a world and
they're all benders they're called the
triple click
Threat triads but there's earth fire and
water benders so this is one of the
earthbending guys
he's uh he's pretty popular and yeah
those we're seeing those slow powerful
attacks yep come against Korra but now
what are we seeing right here he just
got so basically she got countered by
and so Korra can't counter enemies but
the Triads actually can counter her and
so what happens is that you go into this
little sequence and if you fail it then
they end up then then you're at a huge
disadvantage but if you win if you
actually end up knocking them back so
it's kind of a it's kind of an
interesting thing middle it'll take you
by surprise pop-up battle combat
especially when there's more than one of
them is can now is counter like is that
you have a fire counter or a water
counter or is there does the counter
exist sort of independently
bending style it's actually independent
of bending styles - the way it works is
you have a block button and if you hit
with the perfect timing right when
they're getting you you'll actually
counter them depending on their some
moves camp 400 typically lightning base
moves can't be countered by other ones
can and so if you hit right the right
moment you'll have a chance to basically
you flip both sticks up and just knock
them way back whale is earth and fire
water air which one is lightning
lightning is actually not one of
elements so Chi ba come on man well I
mean technically lightnin can be used by
special firebenders but that's not where
that's coming from in this game okay
where's coming from is there are cheap
lockers that actually have lightning
gloves like these gloves that that use
lightning and are as actual electricity
and they shock you and so we'll see one
in just a second he's a red guy that guy
right there
so his moves cannot actually be
countered and so if if he hits you it's
pretty rough but his regular tactic in
there you go and then you can kick him
over the moon yes also there was one to
the lightning getting ahold of him yep
all right well while this oh that's like
sort of a piece in a vulnerable state
because you've stunned and right exactly
opportunity and there's there's unique
finishers for each heading style which
are pretty spectacular like to air the
breakdancing one we saw earlier so
excellent
I guess have a question that this might
be for Caracas on Korra as a character
is much more feisty and passionate less
compared to Aang from the proof from
Avatar The Last Airbender so I guess you
know for me that was refreshing to watch
when I watched some episodes of the show
how was it for you to design the game
how did you sort of go about approaching
her character and making that attitude
come through Monell
microcosm all right she'd some on the
cigar and all cut up the market cool see
cougar I don't like the title know this
sort of killer design is it attacking me
so no honey shoot all my studies for
this yeah absolutely do you know when
you come due to autumn but for you and
also you can occupy this man hi masu you
character Oh motto design through to
your car maken-ki
and all those are keen to know what you
need to but you know flutter game is a
cakewalk
I people to them so we say cause it's a
good to know ma chosen our initials in
the Thomas gave them or
guide us on the path against us on
so yeah and make they kind of from from
a Japanese standpoint they kind of
thought of her like her personality is
being kind of like a tomboy it's kind of
out there refer to it but uh you know
they they considered it quite a
challenge actually to try and pull that
off and make a convincing pom and we
actually did a lot of work together with
Nickelodeon and natural redish from the
show to make sure that we were hitting
that feel properly so it was kind of a
name is a challenge for them because
they haven't really had to do that kind
of thing before they typically don't
work with licensed games as much mm-hmm
that have such an established world and
say that was a bit of a challenge but
yeah it was really a cooperation thing
just making sure we're on track the
whole time when kind of developing her
character so cool yep it looks like
you're anticipating a big encounter here
yep so and actually you could see
Republic City in the background before
it was showing it we're at the this is
the actual super iconic air temple
island where she does a lot of training
in the show mm-hmm and he's got a he's
gonna yeah
mamita little stage it you know
no games are an American Irish or Tokina
and all state enacted under the river
viraja
domo-kun koi no today my character me
constable I know series shooting today
anoche Jeannie Alamitos again
Stairmaster
uh no character dr. Kaku bending law
Coquelin effect Oh Nick honest mo
calamity that I do know I know any mini
muckey night and all quality not pure
tone when I was just so many this car
okay so uh what he is saying is uh so
one thing that they really really
focused on and he wanted it places an
example but they really worked on on
getting the cell shading rights just
really nail a look at the show and not
only that but it was um additionally
like the effects that you'll see in the
game if you look at it from any angle
they did a lot of really meticulous
research in or in short that it was
hitting like that exact look of the show
so that's one of the things that they're
really they're really proud of that
achievement I don't know
hiking a home movies neck I know any
monkeys kokino G in the scale don't know
nothing serious treating doctor Koko K
cotija Kino takagi who know
animal Gonzaga horse again still misled
the matter no fun no kotoba a no convey
territories right I know
bugle this is yeah I know Cora but
arranged a gimmick oh yeah no no no
Cochran [ __ ] about me right they mustn't
there keep your ponytail okay so
something that we think fans will really
appreciate so you'll notice in the
backgrounds they actually did a lot of
work to ensure that it has a kind of a
hand-painted feel you can see it like on
the roofs and on the plants inside over
there they've also included a lot of
stuff that phase of the show recognized
such as you see the bagua training
portion where she needs to be the leaf
and kind of dodge in order to figure out
how to airbend and so they've got a lot
of iconic stuff in from the show like
that so they're they're pretty excited
about it
well that's always a challenge right you
know you want to you guys as game
designers want to bring your own your
your own design sensibility to the game
but you also that kora looks a certain
way she moves a certain way she's in a
certain world so you have to kind of
take that and make it your own
interpretation while still remaining
true to the to the source material right
and so you know PlatinumGames you guys I
feel like one of the things I love so
much about your games I felt Bayonetta
about vanquish is the immediacy of the
action and the speed and just how
satisfying it as a pure play experience
so I guess what what appeal to you about
well I don't to keep you from getting
into the dramatic scene right there but
what can you talk about what appealed to
you about Legend of Korra what what drew
you to the game to want to want to make
it yeah yeah I don't
Jonel soliciting my cheek you can't get
a say
addition of coral take a feel cool I saw
this snare a book no-hoper absolute or
McCune kinda snare ma no muscle activity
on Sonora so you wanna gallo that I keep
coke a you know none of this game or
mother what are you going over you to
steal our car had to interview to school
a nanny or aconitine soccer BioCode
Akira still call this man hi oh no some
scenario mo mo no sugu coo coo macaca
said sorry tennessee for the color
action scenes action scene no animation
most vocal and a comic actor are
smoothing it okay awesome okay so um so
he's saying you know the original
originally it was brought to them by by
a bias packaging but you know when we
when they saw the material because it
doesn't heat me he didn't say this part
but the show doesn't actually air it in
Japan so they don't know about it when
it when it first came out okay so they
saw that but they saw the source
material because we gave it to him in
they were just blown away it was just so
incredibly well done big they were
really really impressed and particularly
this story was justing incredibly well
realized and then the action was just I
mean amazing
right I mean it's like actually my sweet
talker Oh
cuckoo my mediocre getting out of what
about Owen isn't it
they're mysterious not over amo in this
kid or an okay cocora know the idea
romance the Untied isn't it
oh sorry para Keiko oh no comedy comedy
do you come over I knocked over a wall
at a coke instead he do any balance to
that authority to animation dot oh oh no
mori muster under new wonderful Saturday
night this I just didn't adapt on this
you know no so yeah basically
so in addition to those it's also a
sense of comedy it's even got romance
stuff and it's just never there really
impressed by how well balanced the show
is it
yeah so they thought it was really
really cool and that's kind of something
we haven't really talked about it this I
guess the store we touched on it a
little bit at beginning but the story of
the game itself does it you know but I
think are we about to enter like a
little bit of a different gameplay
section here maybe before I asked that
about story okay talking about what's
going on here sure it's the polar
bear-dog
it is indeed so Cora's riding her trusty
Polar Bear Dog Naga and there's there's
various running sequences throughout the
game they're actually connected the
story that's not in infinite Runner
although the gameplay is kind of similar
to other infant runners you made infant
runners you may have seen short um it's
got some unique twists one is you can
actually use different bending styles
and I'll show them to you in a second
but um the really cool thing is the
longer you live with a the longer you go
without dying the faster and faster it
gets so by the end is just totally nuts
so but yeah so this uh he's just used to
what water betting ability is exactly
shield that'll protect them from damage
and all the different elements have
different abilities right now we're able
to use three out of four so others is
getting a little quicker
yeah and this is earthbending so there's
actually a part where even so you can do
double jumps pretty frequently save
yourself from falling and then here is
even we're just gonna quickly show some
firebending beat neck just below step up
yeah I mean there are cool down so you
have to think about a little bit but uh
yeah so that's kind of a fun little ah
size question have you guys thought
about a minigame that involves petting
and cuddling with polar bear-dog
know how huge a nice girl oh my god no I
want another doctor God look how many
other
bukata for your hustle knockout that it
is it it never really occurred
faithfully pitbull no games and I think
it may be a great material for a sequel
though so yeah sometimes it alright
while you're fighting giant robot
sinister Nick diving mega tank yeah
The Legend of Korra you know it takes
place it's sort of a
a more modern setting than Avatar The
Last Airbender it deals with some sort
of issues of bitter that feel more
modern that feel a little bit more
grown-up is that something that the game
touches on as well um
yeah I mean I don't wanna give away too
much about the story but I mean it's
tell me the entire thing Robert yeah I
should do that at this point but uh yeah
I mean there's definitely it's it feels
like the show right the story feels like
the show is what you would what you
would come to expect um she definitely
what I what I can't say she definitely
does spend some time dealing with the
consequences of the decisions you made
in book 2 particularly around what she
decided to do with the spirit world so
are people gonna do some portals you
guys gonna you guys gonna tell the Bukit
the game player what she did in book 2 I
mean is that sort of it's not gonna
require a huge amount of knowledge you
know series yeah you don't have to know
everything that happened it'll me a lot
you'll enjoy it a lot more probably if
you you do in general because your
events will be like oh yeah totally yeah
but at the same time yeah if you haven't
seen the show you're gonna be fine
but it is kind of you know the basic
idea is it's just her dealing with the
decisions you made at the end of book 2
and the consequences of that so at what
I can say is we have a unique villain
yet that comes up in this game that was
actually developed together in between
Platinum Games in studio here yeah I'll
do that make from the show sure and
they're really excited about showing it
it's it's gonna be pretty cool and it's
a guy that took away her bending so
that's a part of it but a jerk yeah
pretty cool finisher set that is the
fire bending finisher just actually just
start off with that moves from a million
times with your fireplace you're gonna
yeah of course of course
well you guys are still working on the
game building up to the release of
Legend of Korra
when is the the game coming out and for
what platforms are going to go to play
it on so right now it's coming out oh so
right now it is coming out in fall this
year yes and if the platforms are Xbox
one Xbox 360 Playstation 3 PlayStation 4
and steam
fantastic yeah well gentlemen thank you
so much for coming on showing off some
Legend of Korra gameplay in action and
talking about talking about the game
here at comic-con much appreciated in
the hunt
oh thank you very much all right folks
that's the Legend of Korra coming out
this fall
take a look keep an eye out for it and
we'll be having more news about it of
course on GameSpot as the release
approaches